Hi, I'm Erik Voss and Venom has a new trailer that finally shows us the slimy, hulking Spidey villain - or a antihero - and
Gives us a new way to say the word symbiote "We call them symbiotes" "Human and symbiote"
Hehughhh... that's gonna be fun to hear over and over again
Let's break down this trailer for all the details that you missed and uh
Spoiler warning in case any of these predictions end up being right! Let's get started.
"Thank you for bringing us collectively to this moment
It is a moment that so many have
dreamed of claiming.
History
starts today."
This trailer opens with the shots of a crash site with the cleanup crew investigating this crashed
spacecraft from which they harvest this symbiote. In the Marvel Comics the Venom symbiote is indeed an
extraterrestrial life-form, a race that calls itself the Klyntar. The symbiote attaches itself to Spider-man on his way back from space,
turning him into a dark, impulsive version of himself, and giving him this cool black suit until Peter Parker
detaches it and it reattaches to his rival at the Daily Bugle, Eddie Brock
This movie appears to keep the symbiotes otherworldly origin while
bypassing the Spider-man step, which does bring up some interesting questions
that I'll get to later.
Over all this we hear the voice of Carlton Drake, played by Riz Ahmed.
He's the head of the Life Foundation, this movie's shadowy
scientific research company that experiments on humans, because you always gotta have one of those.
This movie's story is inspired partly by the 'Venom Lethal Protector' comic,
which features the Life Foundation as a survivalist cult who plan to rebuild society after a nuclear holocaust
They experimented with new forms of the symbiote
to create five soldiers for themselves:
Scream, Agony, Riot, Phage, and Lasher.
In this storyline Venom turns from villain to sort of hero teaming up with Spider-man to take these guys down.
But the big thing to point out in this part of the trailer is that we now see at least two different
symbiotes in the back of Drake's truck.
Notice that they appear to have slightly different color tones.
Maybe it's the light in here, but one of them looks slightly bluer,
and the one in the back has a black-ish grayish color
It's possible that the black one could be used to make the main Venom symbiote that's attached to Eddie Brock,
and the others with different colors will create one of the other symbiote forms, like maybe Riot.
Let me know what you think, but let's move on.
"The guy you work for is the evil person." "I don't work for him, my firm works for him.
Are you gonna behave yourself tomorrow?"
"I told you I want to do my job."
"I'm a reporter. I follow people that do not want to be followed."
"What about the allegations that you recruit the most vulnerable for tests that end up killing people?"
"Your time to go." "You're finished, Mr. Brock." "Is that a threat?"
Okay, in this section we get a sense of what kind of reporter Eddie Brock is. In real life
reporters tend to be like pushy nerds, but not Tom Hardy.
He drives a motorcycle, and he gets big interviews with closed off evil industrialists that he just blows up
with gotcha questions.
I'm Eddie Brock, and I report the truth for Vice, and I don't give a [bleep].
We see him dining with Michele Williams's character Ann Weying. In the comics
Ann is his estranged wife, but here they appear to still be together.
And we learn that Ann's law firm represents the Life Foundation, the company Eddie's investigating,
which, in the real world, would be a pretty serious conflict of interest in a breach of journalistic ethics,
but Eddie Brock is too cool to care about that [bleep]. Joking aside,
I really like Tom Hardy's cavalier take on Eddie Brock. the character needs to have attitude because it's that attitude
that the symbiote feeds on to create the Venom persona. Let's move on.
"You had to learn how to hide in plain sight.
I'm pretty good at it, but you,
you suck.
Whoever you are -" "I work at the Life Foundation, and I need your help
We found something. We call them symbiotes.
Carlton Drake believes that the union between human and symbiote is the key to our evolution."
Okay, here we meet Jenny Slate's character. She works for the Life Foundation.
We saw her standing behind
Carlton Drake in that truck shot earlier. Rumor has it that her character's name is Doris Skirf.
She appears to be some kind of whistleblower, seeking out Eddie to leak some of the evil deeds that
the Life Foundation has gotten into. Notice how the new symbiote we see in
this shot has yellowish streaks on it. Carlton has enclosed a person in there with it
and if that color theory ends up being correct that could make this figure Scream
or Phage.
Scream is the woman Donna Diego, and Phage is a man, Carl Mac.
Could be a woman with the long hair there?
It's a little hard to tell. And yeah,
let's talk about Slate's pronunciation of symbiote as simBYEote.
Yes, it does sound weird and according to Merriam-Webster, this trailer caused lookups for symbiote to skyrocket.
But they said despite symBEEote being the more common way to say it, symBYEote is also an acceptable pronunciation.
So for anyone who has a problem with it being bi,
it's actually okay for it to go both ways.
And real quick,
we see another test subject strapped in in the lab
This could be another one of the five symbiote spawns, perhaps, Raymond Hernandez, who becomes Lasher.
But notice how the monitors that the shot cuts to actually read subject brach, so this is from a different scene,
I'm guessing those shots of Eddie Brock in the MRI, screaming as the symbiote takes over. By the way,
I'm not sure that's an MRI, exactly, because those monitors are measuring decibels and sonic frequencies which are known to aggravate the symbiote -
That's how Peter Parker scared it off - but MRIs use radio waves and electromagnetic energy, not sonic waves.
That was a lot of nerdy stuff there, so let's move on to the next section.
"I'm feeling really sick.
I'm hearing a voice."
"Eddie."
In this section Eddie
Investigates the light foundation labs after hours seeing this one female test subject
This could be Donna Diego scream or Leslie Goodson area the symbiotes agony notice how her enclosure
Appears to have frost on the floor with ice on the services
It's not clear if this is being caused by lower temperatures in the lab or a side effect coming from the woman herself
Whoever. She is she escapes and jumps on Brock. This could be a brockett's infected with the symbiote notice
How as he runs out of the lab?
He's holding his head in his neck with his hand almost as if he was bitten there or maybe that symbiote got into his ear
We see the symbiote begin to infect Eddie's body causing this creepy inky effect on his pupils
and then one of my favorite elements of this trailer the voice of venom I
Am loving the vocal effect and sound editing giving venom this deep demonic rasp
Many of you were wondering who is doing Venom's voice, but from what I can tell it's possible
This is just Tom Hardy himself with a few audio effects either way the contrast between Tom Hardy's voice for Eddie Brock and the voice
We hear from the symbiote in his mind is giving this movie a really cool
Jekyll and Hyde element that really cuts to the core of what makes venom such a cool character
Let's move on you're not real you were just in my head
I'm gonna need mr.. Drake's property back
Why would we do okay in this clip Eddie takes out a bunch of grunts from the life foundation coming to reclaim what he stole?
So I'm guessing whatever Eddie got infected with was the full symbiote sample that Drake no longer has has supposed to do some kind of
Infection from one of the already exposed test subjects the leader of these grunts is rolling Treece played by Scott Hayes
It's interesting to see Venom's power is in action here the symbiote forms into these
Tendrils that protrude out of Eddie's limbs and back to attack these guys now. It's a little tricky because
Traditionally venom takes a sticky web form because it's mimicking spider-man
It was attached to Peter Parker before Eddie Brock and it remembers those spider er
abilities so here wouldn't totally make sense for Eddie Brock's symbiote to
Sling inky webs around the as spider-man hasn't been in the picture now
He might make a cameo in this movie, but he won't be a major part of Venom's origin here
but I guess it doesn't matter because really the star of this is Tom Hardy's acting his reaction to all this seems very natural and
Naturally confused his delivery on why would we do that shows?
How his identity is cracking into two parts and one last thing if you were me you probably miss the big kitchen knives
Hanging on the wall right by the door now
I know this is like a studio apartment
But it's not the safest place to set knives this movie is aiming for an R
Rating so uh it wouldn't surprise me at all to see those knives get used in the fight some very graphic way. Let's move on
If you're gonna stay you will only hurt bad people
Do we have a deal, okay?
Here are some shots of this great street chase with Eddie trying to outrun these
projectile drone missiles also Eddie struggles for control against the symbiote president
You will only hurt bad people remember venom is the hero of this movie, so it can't be all bad
Unfortunately this shot of him looking in the car window before getting slammed back against a brick wall makes me think we might see him
Talking to Venom's presence in the reflection of the glass
Maybe actually we'll get some little nods to Norman Osborn talking to his evil
Reflection in the first spider-man film I could watch Willem Dafoe. Talk to himself in a mirror all day long
Let's move on to the next clue
Willing to sacrifice
Thing you hold most dear
In this section we see some more cool shots of this chase sequence these tendrils grab the steering wheel of the SUV pursuing him and
Then blows back both vehicles. We also see Eddie taking a jog through the woods, and then smashing through this fallen tree
Suggesting that the symbiote is enhancing Eddie's own strength even when venom hasn't taken over
There's also this shot of Anne looking up and concerned now check out the furniture of this room
This is the same location as that overhead shot were a ton of office employees the desktops are being swept away now my last trailer
Breakdown I got into some theories on what could be causing this since this kind of telekinesis
Isn't really one of Venom's powers?
But apparently the target of this attack is and chew on that as we move on to the final section you should be
What the hell are you
I'll fit
After a quick shot at symbiotes spreading across eddies face
There's this quick shot of Eddie Rhee
confronting Carlton Drake telling him you should be extremely afraid to me this sounds like less of a threat as it does a
genuine warning
It's almost like Drake has captured Eddie and plans to go further with his
experimentation and Eddie's saying trust me you should be very afraid of this thing now one thing that's been missing from these trailers is the
Villain that was announced last year carnage. It was rumored that Woody Harrelson
We were playing the role in the comics carnage was created when Eddie Brock shared a prison cell with the serial killer Cletus
Kasady Eddie's symbiote produced an offspring that bonded with Cassidy turning into the far more violent and sadistic
Carnage my guess is that if carnage does indeed come into this story?
he'll be revealed in a later trailer perhaps something this summer like a comic-con and
maybe
Creating carnage is what Carlton Drake is trying to do here in this scene the petty and then after a quick shot of Eddie getting
Some serious air on his motorcycle and his symbiote in drools reattaching him to it
We get the real money shot of this trailer
This is I love the way Venom's toothy mouth closes over Eddie's head as if it's literally
Swallowing him reflecting the way venom swallows and his identity to take over along with Eddie's voice
Transforming from his normal tone to the deeper more animalistic tone
Several rows of teeth the long drooly tongue in the slimy texture all perfectly adapted from the characters classic design
But one big question here is what emblem if any appears on Venom's chest
It's hard to tell from the wide full-body shot
if there's anything there in the comics Venom's emblem is a white spider a
Bizarro version of spider-man's emblems since his identity was a mirrored version of spider-man's identity
But again since spider-man probably isn't gonna be part of Venom's origin here
It wouldn't really make sense for his emblem to be anything spider related
But notice those white colored veins on Venom's shoulder those could be connected to some white design on his chest
Some sources are suggesting that it could be a large V. I guess. It's a little silly, but don't knock it
I got a big V tattooed on my chest for Voss wait
No
not not
Perversion damn people are gonna think that but what connection do you want Sparta man to have in this story is it possible to have
Venom without spider-man or can the anti-hero exist on his own seriously movie execs at Sony are dying to know
Comment down below with your thoughts or tweet me directly at Yale us and follow new rockstars on Twitter for updates on your videos
like and share this video and subscribe to new rock stars for all of our deep dives into venom and spider-man and
Everything Marvel related seriously, we're doing a ton of stuff on a pin if you were this week
So be sure to check out all of those great deep dives. Thanks for watching guys. Bye